Hey.
Everyone, hold onto your dicks.
Next thing I remember, we are in
a cab back to his place.
His mom's place.
My name is Carlos and I
run the world's
only all you
can eat naked buffet.
I'm sorry for spraying rat pee
in your face.
Ahh! (bleep)
Yeah, my high fives
are changing, dude.
They're coming in hot.
Bad credit? No problem.
My dad just died
and I'm strapped for cash
so this is amazing.
Do you laser
your butt hole hair?
I like to use an old fashioned
straight razor.
Yeah, me too.
I'm not gonna take a baby's head
and squeeze it between
my butt cheeks to kill it.
Just to clarify on camera,
I don't wanna ever do that.
In the TV show
the Fresh Prince of Bel Air,
I like, I like light skin Aunt
Viv more than I like dark skin
Aunt Viv.
(everyone arguing)
Okay. Slut shaming,
I draw the line,
because you look at this hamster
and you know she's a slut.
Any good parent
would call their kid a slut.
I'm Eden and I make videos
in food porn.
I'm Jane and I raise, breed,
and slaughter gummy animals.
I will kill the cat and eat it.
I won't eat the cat.
I'm not gonna throw my people
under the bus.
There you go!
Oh my God, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay, can you spin again?
Keep spinning.
Who could look at me,
Lady Gaga and think,
she could play a pop star.
Oh no, I'm my mom
and I'm my grandmother
and I'm alone
and I'm an accordion
and I'm not on the planet
that I thought I was anymore.
Cut. That was pretty good.